today we're discussing the craziest
reveal and form in one piece history and
how everyone who saw it to date reacted
to this most insane development in one
piece we'll take a look at how this the
biggest of reveals changed everything in
one piece chill parking within and smash
that like button if you enjoy these one
piece videos and want to keep them
coming make this the video you join the
Naka by subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications so you don't miss future
one piece videos and updates at the same
time you're also helping us inch closer
towards that insane 2 million
subscribers goal and I would be
eternally grateful for that and now
without further Ado let's jump into It
spoilers and all first we must give
props to zunesha who immediately said
even before Luffy was fully transformed
the following and I quote I can hear it
how long it's been I hear the drums of
Liberation for the first time in 800
years he is here Joy boy has returned
end quote this was when Luffy's face was
all melty and the internet was going
crazy with one of the most insane
onepiece Cliffhangers ever at this point
we were wondering will Luffy even be
Luffy anymore or will he be taken over
by Joy boy than y as it turns out Luffy
was Luffy and just dubbed this new form
gear five so zuna's words seem to
suggest that about 800 years ago Joy boy
had also awakened this same devil fruit
that Luffy has now awakened and Momo for
his part is shocked at hearing this
saying Luffy is Joy boy so yes Luffy is
in a very real sense the return of Joy
boy and in every prophecy that mentions
Joy boy returning you can bet it means
Luffy multiple people responded to
Luffy's powerful hockey in this form a
recovering Sanji suddenly wakes up out
of breath saying Luffy question mark
exclamation mark well a stared cast like
kid law hyogoro and Marco the Phoenix
can't help but notice him too meanwhile
back at marijua the elders are dealing
with the fact that they made kaido angry
and lost an elite agent and some are
wondering if it was worth it just to get
Luffy because keep in mind at this point
they think they did stop Luffy while
Saturn who's played the biggest role
lately in the manga is the one to say
what if I told you that there was a
potential future that would make us beg
for this howcome it is always better to
eliminate dangerous variables end quote
while Elder Ethan Baron adds in every
era the world government has attempted
to recover the gumgum fruit and now once
has it ever succeeded for 800 years it
is as though the devil fruit is trying
to escape our grasp and it very well
might be Zone fruits contain a will of
their own and this particular fruit has
the name of a God the other name of the
gumgum fruit is the Zone type human
fruit mythical model na possessing a
body with the properties of rubber and
fighting in what ever way he fancies
bringing smiles to the faces of the
people the warrior of Liberation also
known as NAA the son God Awakening
brings his body greater physical
strength and freedom it is said that in
all the world there is no power more
ridiculous so although at this point the
elders don't necessarily know that Luffy
has awakened they still react to the
idea of him reaching this awakened State
and they would much rather lose a top
agent and even anger the Yono with the
highest Bounty then even risk Luffy
Awakening we also find out that there is
no power more ridiculous and that this
fruit is so special it's the only one we
know that was given a fake name to hide
the truth furthermore it's so important
that the government has been after it
for 800 years but the will of the
mythical Zone fruit kept evading them
whatever that means Luffy's own reaction
is worth mentioning too he says oh I can
do everything I wanted to do I think I
can fight a bit longer my heartbeat
sounds so funny this is the Pinnacle of
what I can do this is gear five end
quote so even though Luffy himself does
know all the intricacies or the whole
truth he does pretty much realize right
off the bat that this is his final most
powerful form in pretty much all room
for improvement will come down to
refining it that in and of itself makes
this the biggest deal and the hypest
gear not to mention signals to us that
the end of one piece might be closer
than we wish to think k for his part
looks scared when he wonders what's that
on the roof and the people around him
start fainting from the level of Luffy's
conqueror's hockey Luffy then pulls out
kaido with his giant arm like kaido was
a mere snake toy or something chopper
for his part is Overjoyed crying and
waving his arms asking is that Luffy
notably as we'll see his crew doesn't
have the craziest reactions to his form
but a lot of top tier characters with
the most knowledge in the world of One
Piece definitely do after Luffy is
temporarily done throwing around the
so-called strong creature kaido kaido
realizes its straw hat and is actually
to his credit happy he didn't want to
win through cheating but fair and square
so this gives him a second chance to do
just that after Luffy pulls up the
ground to deflect back kaido's blast
breath kaido says given that you're
transferring your rubber power to other
things I suppose I can interpret this as
The Awakening of your paramia powers but
something does not up body
Transformations like that are the
trademark of Zone Powers so here kaido
doesn't know the truth of the fruit but
he knows something is a Miss Luffy for
his part keeps using gumgum in his
attack name showing that he too doesn't
know the truth of his fruit even though
he's awakened it after Luffy drains this
new form for the first time Kido thinks
it's all over he asks who are you you
have my assurances after you die die
someone will tell the tale of your great
battle end quote even as kaido thinks
he's going to win he can't help but be
impressed by gear five Luffy's
performance up to this point Luffy then
reactivates his form despite kaido
telling him to be careful or he'll die
Luffy Associates the form with his heart
hitting that certain beat and once it
does he re-enters the form saying yeah
that's the sound kaido continues to
think about the form as they fight he
thinks what does this mean he turns all
white he uses Armament and the Supreme
King and can transfer his powers to
other things things I've never seen such
Free Will in combat before end quote so
in his own way kaido is pretty much
reiterating what the elders said that
it's the most ridiculous power in the
world making possible what shouldn't be
possible even among devil fruits and
that's saying something during the fight
we again hear from zunesha thinking oh
joy boy it's as though you're right
there my heart is dancing I cannot help
but feel that fate is at work I cannot
help but put my hopes in him end quote
perhaps unesa thinks this because of his
experience with joy boy of 800 years ago
but also it's something that's been tied
to Luffy's character and to the sun god
naika myth people especially the
oppressed want to put their trust and
faith into both of them similar to what
mihawk said Luffy has the ability to
make allies of everyone around him and
that's the most dangerous power on the
sea it could just be a parallel but it
may be a quality of the fruit too since
as we saw with Bellow Betty fruit powers
can encourage people and influence their
feelings kaido tells us something about
Awakening too when he's responding to
Luffy's new form he says Awakening is
what happens when your mind and body
catch up to your powers and those are
certainly ridiculous powers and there's
that word again ridiculous when kaido
Witnesses Luffy grab lightning from the
sky he says so you grab the lightning a
how Preposterous however as impressive
as Luffy's fruit powers are kidos say
abilities alone cannot conquer the world
the world is convenient that way Roger
didn't have any fruit Powers because
only hockey can transcend all this is an
important part of the story because up
until now Luffy's fruit was pretty much
being portrayed as a very broken if not
the most broken power but kaido makes it
clear that the most ridiculous fruit
power cannot make up for a lack of
hockey Mastery like everyone else Luffy
needs to get his hockey on point and
thankfully he has that on lock too as
we're about to see before that kaido
suggests that despite Luffy's Awakening
he still has a weakness to being cut and
it appears that way when Luffy takes his
wind blade attacks as Luffy prepares for
his final attack Yamato is shocked
seeing the size of Luffy's Fist and
saying he's going to punch through the
entire Island kaido decides to take the
attack full on and uses his flame dragon
torch form he assumes Luffy's arm will
melt into nothing before it can come
into contact with himself but he
underestimates Luffy's Mastery of hockey
as Luffy points out the old man taught
me how to do that without touching I'll
smash you all the way to the bottom of
hell as Luffy wins The Clash he screams
that he'll create a world where his
friends can eat as much as they want and
kaido's eye snaps open as if in shock
before he sent deep into the Earth kaido
thinks about what he told King way back
when that dry boy is the man who shows
up and beats him in the future and so
that's exactly what Luffy did in his
gear five form so it's interesting that
both kaido and zunesha are in agreement
that gear five Luffy is the new era Joy
boy we already saw how scared the elders
were by the idea of awaken Luffy so it's
not surprising that when they see his
new form in his new Bounty poster they
freak out top man war cury is the one
that says he wants it reprinted because
of the new form and the fact that the D
was removed from the name as asked if
you'll remember they did that with gold
D Roger by changing it to Gold Roger as
well in a way so it really seems like
Luffy is getting up to that pyate King
level big news Morgans though loves
Luffy's new form calling it that
mystical form and ignores orders telling
his Messengers to carry these far and
wide shank's crew after the new posters
come out and Luffy gets his new Yono
status now know that Luffy is a great
pirate lucky Ru even suggests going to
see Luffy now when they're near wano
yaso however says he's not ready to see
Usopp yet Shanks for his part looks at
Luffy's awakened form and thinks well
well he also thinks back to when he got
the fruit from a government ship and the
government agents were shocked thinking
there's no treasure here just a single
devil fruit the government agents also
think what could that mean to them it
just turns you into rubber we also get a
flashback of shank sacrificing his arm
for Luffy thus through shank's reaction
and thoughts I'm all but certain that he
knew about the truth of this fruit and
now he's happy to see that Luffy was the
right one to awaken it Shanks then says
he's not interested in seeing Luffy to
Lucky Ru shock rather he decides it's
time to deal with bomeo who has been
causing trouble in his territories and
putting up Luffy's flag also it seems
Shanks really feels the kick in the
pants now with all the progress Luffy's
made and says to Beckman let's claim the
one piece in other words it seems like
shank's reaction to this new Awakening
of Luffy and his new power and status is
to treat him as a serious rival he is
nice enough to scare off greenbull from
wano before he goes though so Luffy can
get the rest he deserves after beating
kaido then we get to Egghead and we get
to see Luffy's gear five form again when
he faces awaken Lucci as Luchi points
out to Luffy he's not the only one
that's gotten stronger on a side note I
love that about one piece it's an
evolving world where even beaten
opponents can make progress and come
back so Luchi reaction to the new form
is pretty much so what I'm stronger too
and I've awakened too Vega Punk's
reaction is more interesting since after
all he's one of the most knowledgeable
characters in the series he says in the
oldest books of devil fruits there is no
such thing as a gum gum fruit this
confuses Usopp who says he's always
going gum gum this and gum gum that but
back to VAP Punk and he is deeply moved
when he sees the new form he says what a
beautiful sight has the warrior in white
appeared he asks tell me what is this
transformation exactly Nami answers we
don't know either isn't this his gumgum
power Vega Punk continues saying he
looks just like a god who only appears
in the oldest of texts Sanji responds a
god he's Luffy you know he's a
right and Vega Punk answers indeed the
foolish and laughable Warrior of
Liberation who brings smiles to all
people also known as NAA the son God
Nami says she's never heard of NAA and
Vega Punk responds you wouldn't have
then he continues for a while but I got
to read it all because it's such huge
information that we've been waiting for
forever he says it's a name that's been
erased from the historical record but as
long as people wish for him his
existence will never truly disappear all
things are brought into this world with
hope even the devil fruits every devil
fruit is a possibility for human
evolution that someone desired if only I
could be like this if only I could be
like that all of those Powers represent
the many branches of the future of
humanity but that unnatural status is
loaded by the seed the mother of nature
A fitting punishment for its sin those
with powers exist in different
dimensions dreamed up by someone else
before them such a fascinating world end
quote meanwhile when sentomaru sees
Luffy he just comments you got that
weird look going on in response to his
gear five form so I love how different
everyone's response is unfortunately
sentomaru gets attacked by Luchi midt
talk Luchi for his part thinks after a
while where is awakened Luffy getting so
much force he says he feels his mind
slipping away from him but before Luffy
can knock him out completely he escapes
with his crew and returns to his droopy
drained form awaken Luffy as you'd
expect jumps from one top tier opponent
to the other and next he fights Admiral
kizaru the man who looked so untouchable
especially pre time skip after fighting
a bit Luffy finally decides it's time to
use gear five and he appears in giant
form and grabs kizaru with his giant
hand a shocked and sweaty kizaru says
there it is so this is the thing you do
immediately kizaru says well this is no
good after some fighting kizaru tries to
escape to complete the mission clearly
gear five Luffy is not an opponent he
can quickly overpower and he knows that
even more impressive is how Luffy can
tank kizaru's attacks and even catch up
to him a guy with light power is known
for his speed and out of breath kizaru
even says listen I'm sorry but if I
spent all my time on you you I can't
fulfill my mission and then after
getting hit with Luffy's star gun attack
kizaru says he's seeing stars and is
rendered immobile for the time being
Saturn for his part immediately
recognizes Luffy as NAA when he sees him
falling from the sky Saturn goes for
Luffy's withered recovering Bonnie when
he gets a chance but Luffy is saved by
Frankie Saturn at one point says Luffy
and Bonnie we fail to anticipate your
presence here but if your fate is strong
enough to escape this desperate
situation I would very much like to see
it he definitely seems confident in his
abilities that's for sure it's during
this Arc that we also learned that Kuma
the last of the buccaneer race knew the
story of Nika and wanted to be just like
naika so he could save the imprisoned
and suffering he passed the knowledge of
the son God down to his adopted daughter
Bonnie too he led her to believe that na
will come to free her too so the big
awaken Luffy helping Bonnie moment and
Bonnie making the connection between
Luffy and NAA is definitely one big
upcoming moment to look forward to we
even saw during Kuma's flashback that
he's betting on Luffy he compared Luffy
and NAA and said that if there there is
a hero who will bring a great
transformation to this sea he thinks it
must be Luffy the fact that Luffy ended
up having the NAA fruit is just too
perfect and recently someone gave Luffy
food so he can recover quicker and
hopefully fight Saturn it's not
confirmed but a lot of people expected
to be kizaru who was shown at the time
simply with an enigmatic three dot
speech bubble I've been saying for a
while that kizaru's internal struggle
has been coming to a boiling point this
Arc so maybe this is him finally
deciding hey maybe fighting against a
little girl and my friends rather than
this clearly evil demon guy is not the
right move and like Luffy and NAA tend
to do perhaps Luffy one k through over
to his side that would definitely make
it more believable that the straw heads
could escape this desperate situation as
Saturn called it now if you like
learning more about the truth behind
Luffy's devil fruit then you won't want
to miss my video about Zoro and sanji's
devil fruit Powers link on screen right
now like And subscribe to help us reach
2 million subscribers here on YouTube
and I'll see you in the next one